hello and welcome to this video playing
agricola corner yeah after the bad game
before I hope to manage something good
you have a fantastic score against the
sky 14 out of 17 that sounds pretty good
can I da goon felt with a score of that
type man judging by the last game I
cannot dare to play chess at orbit we'll
see what happens here it takes a million
years for every move yeah I'm trying to
convey the impression that I actually
know something here which I don't can i
play b5
sometimes this could be one or something
like that okay I'll try really making
things up here I can probably see six
you can take take Quinn be one huh ok
I've 25 maybe right looks shaky ok so
maybe a sixsome make that look a little
bit more solid ok so white claims
compensation here for pawn on what
grounds Bishop f3 may be simply ok
Jim now what has some pressure here on
my on my pawns I would like to take with
the sea porn after a takes be five but
this is not going to work so they have
to be content with this one okay um how
to do this here Knight b6 night a for
would be good if i get that in i think
i'll i'll cover this first year e e
seven yeah he definitely has some
compensation as absolutely absolutely
the case how to do that maybe i can I
would really like to play civ 5 here in
this position Bishop g3 f-35a rc5 is
that playable TX takes hmm it's probably
not ideal but yeah anyway I'm I guess
okay wow just wow move is that I don't
understand it at all okay white resigns
okay well heck shocking we should be
seven um yeah okay I'm not sure that I
can actually grab this pawn here but be
five I feel it looks a bit dodgy yeah
but I mean the computer doesn't find a
direct refutation which is kind of
reassuring I think that white players
very often they get this trying to get
this back quickly I'm not sure maybe
this is also ok but I'm really just
literally made that up over the board so
I tried to keep that porn and all those
moves look totally normal yeah this yeah
also look fairly fairly standard and now
again now we can take yourself which I
overlooked now we can take this
interesting yeah okay I have this trick
but Bishop c5 check yeah yeah I have a
very weird looking Bishop him now yeah
this is not so bad for black but he
should have played that more and now i
get this move in and I'm benim yeah um
how does that continue if he doesn't
blunder yeah I mean this is just good
for black here I'm maintaining a pawn
and a really good position this is we
get it's a tempo so this
isn't working at all night c5 maybe then
I wanted to take him and after this this
this should be good I was a little bit
in doubt because he goes it see get
sassy pawn as well but it's not a big
thing i can i can get this probably like
this this and then take it yeah this is
plundering a piece yeah okay do not a
lucky win but it basically gifted me the
point there okay thanks for watching